this is going to sound like it's out of
a movie it's not this is not out of a
movie I'll send a link to you
on what just happened in Iran and if you
read this you're almost going to say
yeah I don't know if this is true Iran
has hanged three people on drug charges
amid continuous continued criticism of
its execution practices and increased
death penalty sentences the three men
identified as shahab Mansoor nassab
Samad gervant and Saeed jervant were
hanged after more than 39 kilograms of
heroin they're saying that's what the
reason was and precursors and processing
equipment were confiscated with them
Judiciary uh website set on Sunday now
that's the story you're reading I'll
give you another story for you to read
Rob is this one I'm about to send to you
these guys that just went through this
there were anti-government protests they
were not supporting what they're doing
in Iran today and they spoke out about
it okay if you can pull up the link I
just sent you and Iran sits there and
says yeah this is kind of we got to make
a statement too so Iran executes three
men accused over anti-government protest
us Iran has executed Three Men and said
it was implicit in their deaths of three
members of security forces during
anti-government protests drawn
condemnation from rights groups and the
EU and risking further International
isolation uh uh so that story you pull
up was a different story than this one
here Rob these are two different stories
were killed on Friday morning the Tasman
agency reported crowds had gathered
outside the prison where they were being
held on Thursday night as rumors of
their imminent execution grew cultural
figures inside and outside Iran as well
as family members had steeped has
stepped up a campaign over the past
weekend to Halt the executions on the
grounds that Iranian authorities had
failed to produce definitive evidence of
the men responsibly for the deaths of
two members of besiege parliamentary
force and law enforcement officers on 16
November so it goes and goes telling
these different stories go on Twitter
now to see what's trending right now go
on Twitter to see what's trending right
now
go to Twitter and see on the right
what's trending King if you go to more
of them to show one of them should be
king Reza palavi is trending 16 17 000
on my screen it shows us number three uh
if you're typing chingara's up however
you make it have a hard time spelling
that here's what's going on uh uh with
Iran when events like this happen Iran
just a year ago they had so much
momentum so much momentum with what was
going on you're seeing Reza palabi the
son of King Reza pallavi the gentleman
right there then I have at multiple
meetings together had multiple
conversations together people in Iran
are starting to worry about what's going
to happen and he is all over the place
right now uh talking about the fact that
this is an opportunity for Iran to be
free we can live in a country like
America for people that complain about
America when's the last time you went
outside and you said you know what
they're hanging three different people
today outside of DC yeah you know what
happened these guys talked against the
president and they're hanging them what
you're serious that would never have
just out of movies no that actually just
happened in Iran that those types of
things are still happening in countries
like Iran and uh I I you know it's such
a weird position for them to be in
because on one end parents want to see
Iran be free again but the fear of
getting their kids to be motivated by
this and they go out there and all of a
sudden like man I lost my son the parent
parent doesn't want to experience risk
in something like that
um so you can encourage them and say
look keep fighting I was like you're not
even in here to know how ugly it is what
do you mean keep fighting it is a
decision they need to be making but one
of my uh dreams is to one day take my
kids to Iran and show them where their
father was raised and I lived there 10
years and how the history of this Empire
that they went from being where they
were at to the king building Iran into a
place where women finally had a voice
but it'll be interesting to see what
happens here I like seeing him all over
the place uh the son talking about this
there's more and more momentum going on
there but this was a tragic event that
just took place in around this week and
this is amazing perspective something
that um that really
um
clicked for me is when you shared the
story of when you first came to America
and your mom was watching just regular
news and the commentator was saying
something negative about our president
and what was her reaction she says poor
guy they're going to kill him tomorrow
because that's normal in Iran you don't
talk against uh uh you know presidents
that's just not something you do in Iran
you don't do that in America it's normal
in America it's a business model like
we're doing it today last two hours this
is what we've been doing I'd be homeless
otherwise you wouldn't be homeless maybe
five of us outside today so it's like
hey Rob's gonna say look I'm just
working here man I wasn't doing anything
I'm just having my drink and enjoying it
but it'd be me Adam Rob and Tom uh
outside of item in a statement being
made talk about us one more time that
would be the case in Iran so if you like
this clip and you want to watch another
one click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]